good evening i normally one of the
most difficult tasks i don't know why but
an ability to always be between the
last sessions
i think people tired after lunch and dinner
so we will try to keep a little
alive the attention is still welcome on
my part to give  andreoli technique
program manager in the part
of google cloud professional services
what we talk about today we will talk a bit dg
suite as photoup also from the
presentation that many of you have
already participated in and we will talk about the
rome road map which translates into q3 q4 so
next six months indicatively  and
some ideas of how we are thinking
in terms of what we are going to do
on the suite part
I have this fantastic slide which is
almost useless for those who have been here now
they have already done everything for people
from noberasco etc. that goes here
they stole me  part of the
presentation was this so I don't like to
repeat it and I believe a lot in the change
while in the transformation d  igitale for
what I have experienced in my career
and the fact that gi suite and it
is not simply a project by tino I will
never tire of repeating to customers here
I go that in part with which we collaborate
in something more a cultural change
how many of you are customers  Jesuits in the
hall
I would say almost all excellent excellent someone
who is not so someone who
raises his hand shyly we have it
perfect but then you know what g
suite is I would say yes that is most
of the good in short it is in here and maybe
expects and to discover something
something more but definition we call 12 suites
and this is the only suite of
intelligent acs but which have been designed
to make sure that teams can
collaborate together and move even faster
you have also heard for who it was to do  a
presentation prior to
collaborating in an easier way made
to work faster and so
on
but what are the products?
they are g suite well we have the
main ones are these 15 products you
all know me
try to do a test the challenge the laser
the first there in the upper right
this this
very good perfect what are then
put 15 products in the south to
collaborate more easily but what are
the  Google investment themes where
we go to invest time and resources
so that it can be a product that
can always be better than
respect believes that and it is these five
who are the ones I will talk to you about today
we have a part of the team because
today it was and  the first tool created for the
cloud in mind to facilitate
collaboration between
people we had heard it mentioned before we
will talk about it again security this morning
you saw the presentation of the keynote
of which gabriele we talked about
common security maybe he also did
some in-depth analysis secure by design
what does it mean that when we think
about security in google we think it
from the beginning  in the end
from the data center to the end user
up to your device whether it is ios
android or your pc chrome here is
what you use
but also to think in terms of
what we define productive bionic
then go beyond
productivity
first  we talked about the chain of
sant'antonio of emails
so this continuous exchange there
are activities that are boring to do
but we will talk about
what we try to do to
exploit because they are also
mesh mechanisms the burning within
our apps to do in  way to make
life easier users there are
things that bother us to do
during the day the working day
raise your hand who for those who are not so
turn on the pc and there is something
a fisherman does beyond maybe  of the
work did not have what we are
platform fourth point the platform
is only to our platform and they are
a part of your ecosystem of
our environment
so what c  Let's try to do is and
then we will also see how to try to
integrate more and more and better
within your environment and
last but not least as the Americans would say
and the theme of usability a
product can be technically valid
beautiful beautiful architecture
if it is not usable people do not use it and
therefore our effort is to
make the product as simple as possible
above all to bring back the experience
will consume internal inter price which
is something that is not quite so
simple to do but it turns out
that we are having  the client saw it
the adoption they were suite a
little bit we are succeeding
we are now talking about tims so of the five
we go to deepen the themes see
what we have done what we will do
in the next few months we
draw because the idea is to do
so  that users can work
together safely ok
the other day we were working on an
important race we were for  i know ten
people we were writing on the
same document were 180
page rfp something like this is people from milan
agent from turin agent from england
we are all collaborating together on the
same document there was a moment of
panic the document disappeared  it was
white
I did a refresh it was white my
colleague that the absence started mind
seems in the hair
among other things my colleague did the
reverse of the latest version we
fixed all this and
work collaboratively in a safe way
on this l  'another thing is to enable
users to be more effective than to
contribute to the best
within their company to be able to
do things at their best and last year
is a very important point
to make the
collaboration of users feel real when we were
working  all together the other
day on his document he studies or
almost the pressure people typing
in a hurry we have to deliver d  we have
to deliver on this also because
actually I was able to
collaborate very closely on this point
but what are the innovations that we are
introducing are three the main innovations
that I want to talk to you today some have
already been announced are already
available but the first will be available later
hangouts chat you know that they are
finally trying to
clarify collaboration systems
videoconferencing chatting and so on
then hangouts out of four those on the
track for the adopts program
means that for some users some users are already
available who
have made a request
the nice thing that we are going to
introduce integration with native gmail
there will be an interoperability between lenga
classic hélène gap chat because in any case
it will not go to die immediately in gauteng will
coexist in the moment we will try chat
and mild available is
another very nice feature especially
for those  like me he works with fellow
American Indians etc.  to
the tag heuer two notes disturbance and I think
but the web maybe at night and maybe in the
morning for montand more I would like to
sleep too but basically I
try to sleep at night
another very important thing that is always
a mess
this is this being able to do  a
meeting to videoconference in a
simple way and I have to find the conference number and I ca
n't find it what is the link
and it doesn't work these are problems that
I think anyone in here in a
conference system has experienced our
goal is to
minimize looking  to optimize with a series
of things from optimizing the
use of the mail to the fact that
in the enterprise version we will soon have
support for 50 simultaneous users
on what will be thanks to being
able to send private test chats
with users without disturbing
the  presenter and so on
then a whole series of features
including the mobile one that will allow the
user to make more f  it is easy for
all users to participate another
important thing is that it has
now been introduced currently gives the
possibility to call a
phone number to attend the meeting I
am in the car I have to participate I
cannot drive you should not be
driven and in the meantime participate  at
the video meeting I can call today
we are available on the
international number us soon will
also arrive new phone numbers on which you
can connect other innovations
introduced is related to google sites and
google sites can become a bit of a
point of reference
within the  company be something that always
via prato mazar and therefore it can be
more and more optimized to
make the creation of
websites easier and easier for the complex ones
there are developers there are good people
with html5 css everything you want
java javascript zither  here instead you need
something quick and earth that is easy
to use and easy to use  customize
and that can also allow you to give a
greater degree of larity in what are
the controls of those who can access can
see the site
but now let's go back to the topic of security and
security by design
even here we have three points that we said
are important therefore the possibility of
building  from
from the data center to the user how to
go from this morning we
develop the hardware both of the switches
everything was developed internally to
avoid the least possible number of
attacks but above all the certainties of
having another fundamental point must
be simple to use both for
administrators who
make things complicated for users and users
will find a way to overcome them so it is
extremely important that it is simple
both because they have to administer the system but
also for those who have to use it and
especially in Italy but as a Europe
also in the United States there are
a whole series of rules that must be
respected for the cloud world and therefore
we help you in this some of you
know the galley clinic in milan
you know that famous klien famous here in
milan for giving birth to children and second
because it is considered one of the best
clinics beyond subject to the will
of doctors and midwives etc. because the
milanese
al  beyond having leffe 205 they did not go
to san raffaele because if he was born in segrate they
go to the rooster eater at the rooster eater on
average between 6 and 7 thousand
children are born a year
so you can imagine
obstetricians nurses nurses
whoever is inside
how many have seen how many
problems have seen
premature babies etc. but what the hell are you
telling me about the investment because
this is for me to make another
comparison which is why google is
able and is extremely effective in
managing security in preventing
phishing malware
even now the latest ramsauers who
are  just released this morning
evolution of pt it seems to me that yes
last calls that came out for this
because in any case insecurity skies meter the
more
things happen the more things we see the easier it is
to predict it
we have as it has been repeated perhaps
several times today seven products with more than
a billion active users every
day gmail roma android al search
youtube maps and so on
and so this is an important point
being able to see all the
colors and allows us to be good at
managing security but I ask you a
question which are in your opinion the points
for which I do not have a  yes or a be
it a sit security of if they stay
awake at night but maybe pull small children
which are working speaking the
things that keep them awake at night
someone who is not don't be shy as
the Americans say what are the
problems  security that can
keep a hitman awake
I understand sorry
virus it could be that we go into
words more than this case fishing mobile
management then  the mobile effects management
we said before brignano device
mentioned before our client
said I have to manage the brigan devices
rather than the loss of data data
breach state
the fact that the data can go
out inadvertently or not from our
company and what we do as google
for  prevent all this
first of all at the level of
Venetian phishing the first most common way with which
malware and ramsauer are sent good
cry tells you something method was
sent through a difficult system then
exploiting the world of ability to
the operating system etc.
etc.  this is because the passwords but
there is a tendency to
raise their hand who does not use a password
for at least two sites so the fact that
the password can be easily
reused then try in the
shadows all gross
and there is also the other beautiful thing
this morning  also gabriele during the
presentation by the atp is not
that it seems more secure one time password
not  it is also very sure why
via sms these things here then
what have we done an amen looked
for technological points to insert a
further check in gmail that this
antiphishing security check that works
through masci duty but what
does the email do then and could  arrive that
seems healthy let me tell you so
the link that
arrived as phishing has not yet been cataloged what do we do
then when I click on the
link a search is made for the link
that I am going to access and if fiji
gets my ankles ne  I am notified this
availability is already available on
the web and on android and will be available
in q3 for ios devices
so if even the emails at the moment
seem valid to me because I have not yet
discovered that that link itself is
actually phishing thanks to mechanisms
I can choose me  go to improve
the other important one that gabriele also mentioned
this morning but that given the
keynote this is
the use of the se  curities so I is
then as I said walking this morning is
something I know the password something
I have that is this usb key I know in
google
if there is not this we are finished small parts
give two for safety
then there are those who also lose the second but
with  another theme therefore is, however, even if you
lose it I can make the covers I can
do
them I can go and disable them that is
what made it easy for me to
use these securities within the dg
suite
so if you want me dear users if it
is not beautiful then  that big so you don't
see even if finally a usb port
disappears completely every now and then
for the touch but otherwise it works very well
and they are idiots that in the notes of
this presentation it says
you can also put them as the candies
left reception and not  security is expected
who thinks not to cook
this then but what is the other theme
we were saying about which I think everyone in this
evening more or less has to do
the management of fleets  mobile that
are tablets that are
that if not smartphones that are ios that
are android enough I would say let's stop that
these two
which are therefore the
mobile value features never manager sorry what
are the issues that I have to go to
face but certainly the
device management that are corporate  but as
the colleague customer mentioned earlier the bio of a
possibility to work with that the
possibility of customizing the devices
then go and say which are the
policies not to be applied you want to do
on which you can connect the
possibility of going to give
working functions then
applications from the company store and
so on
above all check what
these devices do then
reporting system how they were used and so
on
and also do actions in black boats at
least massive devices
these are all features together with
all those you see under
the encryption  write that there is between that
must be used in the
mo  ment in which I go to manage my
fleets of devices
so what has been what will happen
in the next months related to this but
there is a strong development effort in the
noble part they knew it is not at the levels of
specific market solutions mention
a mobile  the heron voices that do only
that but the version that is included in c
suite and that is included in the license so
not recently it is slowly growing in
functionality and snow will arrive many
others in the next few months
from the possibility of
whitelisting the  application based
on organizations together with a better
management of ios devices to a future
support of the def for ios to an
improvement of the cole policies to
apply on the android devices and therefore
a whole series of features that I will
present to go to manage my
conduits and corporate fleets  and therefore not
also bio and of in a much much
easier way but let's go back to another important point
the precise date but clearly opens  a
theme that goes a little beyond the technical side
because if, as you know a few years ago,
an important red car manufacturer
had important precise data
and you caught them making
photocopies in Germany, then
even though they had equipped themselves to
limit  from the technological point of view
the loss of data unfortunately in short
they had some problems and I
happened to speak with both me and
in short he told us that what they do
is to try to protect us as much
as possible from what is an internal attack
substantially but then how does it do  google
help you in this part of data
whit of lp with already knowing that
they had introduced a whole series of
features to protect
the native ok application then the
gym and data loss prevention introduction
to san francisco next of the dlp to
turn for the part  of drive a whole
series of clips on nes mine and so on
and all this allows you to
protect the applications that are
born  vi inside but if I
use applications that or integrated and that
use out as a mechanism then an
integrated authentication mac integration system
that basically what it does
allows me to use a single sign on
and multiplications the risk is that
these applications can have
access to a little too much data
what I can do is that I can
decide a priori which
applications are
I administrator can decide a
white list of third-party applications
that can run within
my domain this then decreases
the attack surface because
applications that have not been
whitelisted will not be able to
access my data used we have
done to improve the
data breach part is the part of google plus
google plus allows me to go
now and will allow you with m
in the next versions to go and
see how the user is using
then have some user  the air useless
metrics therefore of the metrics of how
the user is using it to
have hate tel.org apr to also
know what he did should he connected and
so on
the possibility of checking if I want to
share some post or some
information can go  to check
on which domains after doing or not and then they
can also have commissions
that can be restricted to multiple
domains note what is important clearly
in security it is absolutely useful to
prevent but also to go and try to
understand what happened and then
we have what we are going to  to do is
what is a securid reporting axis
that will allow you to have a security
extended export that you see here on the
blackboard a security check if you close
investigation tool here in the room there are
then some partners I see
known faces in the room that
together with you do not  they can help
make security assessments so they are
services that are like google if as a
partner we can of  frire also to
help you make
the infrastructure related to your
company safer,
now we come to the third point which is
that of the north productivity, that is
to go help the user to do
things that are a bit boring and therefore
what are the three points  main
of the non-productive way you the part
of automation authorization
sorry for repetitive and
boring activities that are done during the
day or assist the user who
has better particular skills
to obtain better results and
above all help the user to have
access to information  relevant
what is one of the main problems in
a company
when we talk about meetings
getting people to agree but
before finding a room find one I
don't know a little better but normally
together in which you work to have been
a natural disaster a room  meetings
returned to his irony and however find
the right time when everyone is
available c  how we did it and
therefore try to improve this
situation and make
life easier for our users with times time
ago in meta a function integrated
in the calendar that will allow you
to automate the search for a room
so when I go to  enter the
number of participants and if I
need a projector or not it
will automatically search for a room
based on the availability to work
participants based on the number of
participants and so on so that everything will be
easier to do
will have detailed information
then  where is how many people
can it contain what kind of team while
therefore they are the projector they are the video
conference on the
information assistance in the meeting costs therefore
a management of the quarrels you have
during the meetings is but is trying to
optimize the way in which the  meetings
come schedule you and then one last dir
action has so I wasn't quite saying
when the idea is  create a
dashboard so that the administrator
can also go to free clan rooms have
been booked unnecessarily which
happens systematically I book the room
and then I do not go there
then since I have presented it I
cannot delete it which is therefore this
instead will allow me  from administrators to
do mental cleaning that have not been
used
another very very nice thing that is
also integrated with the part of mit and
therefore chat and it is the boat that mit
so during I am writing so
a step from a virtual meeting I have to
pass  a physical meeting there are
four of us in the chat
what I can do is ask et mit
find a timer this hit will go to see
the times at
which the people who
are participating in the meeting are available and will
therefore create limitation another thing that we
will always do  to improve
people's lives and this you know that now
we have gmail etc in the boxes you
know there is nice material design
etcetera  ra of the homeland germain what will
happen is that inbox is a bit
used to experiment with things but
the nice things that work
inside a box will be gradually
integrated into gmail gmail will undergo
big changes and reveal interface
next year ok  2018 we still talk
about as good as when but there will be in short
there is a lot of work and among which
some formations network material design
refresh that a little what
unites development on android is development
of the web part now in the nice things
that  I have learned this part of the
smooth that there will be therefore the fact of
having to do an e mail
I do not want it to be in the inbox because
it bothers me at the moment I can do
blues until tomorrow so it
will no longer appear in the inbox miri will appear
tomorrow so new mark it red  not
red I keep it there they look at it concerns it
today I have no time the guard tomorrow is
lately it reappears in
the inbox fourth point
flat  aforma the Venetian platform is
something that allows you to support
in the environment
that you work in and
basically that runs away is the goal
we have in mind
in the investment we are going to make is
to provide an open platform
and  unified on all google apps, it knows to
provide a rich set of api api to
enable third-party developers
to integrate reconnect
natively it will emanate seamlessly with
sweets and enable users to extend
the tajine suite functions with other
activities we have here 4 related points
to the platform the part of goode cloud
search you know for me is one of the
most beautiful things we have introduced cloud
search you have used in g suite silk to
do research finds everything
inside and above all shows you
the latest documents you are
working on
in the meantime you get lost there appear what
will happen in the direction so it
is not something that will happen tomorrow but that you
will  ogliamo do and that
this search and google functionality are I think it is
quite known the goodness
of the search engine can be
used not only to search for
information within my
minus my domain
but that can integrate through adiyiah
stick and with mine  corporate environment or
a crm
the goal is to integrate
applications within cloud search
also with crm or another data source
also integrate with
this other data source and to provide
functionalities at the
front end level  so that it is
as close as possible to the need of the
single company
this quick video showing
the cloud search features if you don't
know it go and try
it really went very much as
you have been looking for the person shows me all
the documents associated with the email and  so on
another important point I see some
developers also inside the
room is the possibility of what we
are working on  and on the extension of
the up script part you know it wrote is
development programming language
that there was interact that allows you to
extend the functionality of
your applications what are the news
but let's quickly discover the
main driver species know that the
tool  of monitoring that there was
internet and the platform therefore the
possibility of monitoring the app scripts
directly within the
monitoring system other important things is that
the in which 26 second to the third point the
part of abb script ap ai will allow
the administrator  to go view
distribute and depress
applications directly from the
centralized console which is like the second
point the ubs vitamins will be able to see which
are installed how they are installed and
so on
other things there will be improvements
from the platform point of view etc.
someone has instead seen
ap maker there is someone who is within
the pop the program someone who i am
using nobody
you know what I am here mail but someone
who says yes someone I know says
moves the stage head yes yes then to
promise a very very
nice tool that allows even non-
developers to be able to develop
applications only a
visual tool that  allows you
to write not to write code wanting to
extend or writing some code
java script rooms and allows me to go to
insert as you see the map of the
databases and very fast that can
be local databases stored
internet drives or I can also
connect to cloud sequel queen  and that
then spread a never sequel as a
date month and then create simple
ticketing ordering applications and
so on without having to write a line
of code
then clearly if you want to spend on you
want to go and extend it by
exploiting the other features and you
supports on hulk script another very
important thing is that to date there are some
acts  life always with a view
to improving the functionality of
making life easier for the user
cela postici will be the possibility of jim
reardon now there are stations that
can be used that work
and integrate with gmail the
difference between bones is that  in reality it integrates
not actively with the functionality
of the email and therefore as you can see
here my new invoice is
integrated directly into the interface
so there will be new
features for gmail both on the
web and android and ios so we will
provide contextual hooks  alimena
then the doctors will decide it will be some
information you check an invoice
automatically the invoice appears for example to me
so this is an evolution of
what generates already can do as
we said the will is to
integrate the platform that already exists
within the  your environment
still living quite awake and therefore we are
the last effort e  we are at the fifth point
that that of the hughes of usability
therefore of usability we said before
what is the was a fundamental point of
usability must not require
training that is, the product must be as simple as
possible not to have to
explain how it works then after there are
the functionalities  advanced there is up script
there is a whole series of things on which
maybe I also have the engineer because
I want to switch from excel
video to powerpoint slides and so on
so that's another thing but
the use must be so simple
and immediate  that the user does not have to
think about holding up a manual to be able to
use e-mail or a product
the other thing is to offer
what consumer grade google angela
consumes, we know, however, in short, he has
created an enterprise infrastructure that
we are happy to  then being able to offer
our customers so we are very good
at making this experience lucky that it is
above all even more uniform in the
form possible  from the web, both on
ios and on android and another
fundamental point for the
jeans suite projects and it is the last one, the easier it is
to use the product the more users will
use them in the company the more users the
more productive they will be the greater the
l  'effectiveness the success of the project
within my company is what
we are doing to help and
further improve the usability
give they would see you all know the
driver then exact stamp and
in the evolution one of the things is to
do and make it a system even
more  easy to use and one of the points is
what is drive file stream you know
that now there are
synchronization clients for windows for mac can
clan who, as the Americans say,
is not quite as effective and
efficient as the
drive le part will be  strings would have
experienced that an eno client who will have
put vocals but which will be much more
effective of the caching mechanisms than
that goes into detail but ch  and it
will make it much easier to
use your to do when you
are offline you are on the plane you have to do some
work somewhere where there is a
connection you will have the possibility to
have your documents also saved and
then you also have access locally
thanks to this mechanism
synchronization there will be the possibility
and to tell about the office and pdf files a
greater request was that of the
possibility of going in series between the
search within the
specific folder and not on the whole driver and then
the possibility of setting
metadata in a  to make
the searches more effective information second
point is the calendar
calendar exceeds 1 you can see which
interface if someone already has access
to the new interface otherwise what
you see a preview is very very nice
all in material design and it will also be much
easier to manage there  will be
very interesting features
from the point of view even before being
published  ng of creation of the
modification appointments and so on
it but now in the phase of 37 foreign
the release should be around q4
so we are between October and December
let's say end of the year could be
the other tip
many of you have raised your hands when
I asked who is g suite client
I suppose you had another
mail system before normally how many
had exchanges has a little bit of news
so skip thing that anything else
wins anyway for whoever found himself
having to manage
one of the points exists in the migration to exchange part
important
clearly vesco migrate 100 200 500
1.000 and 10.000 users in one night had
an interregnum time interoperability
between systems and it was a bit
difficult point because the tools were not
effective the tools did not work
one that version of xen 2013 2016
were not  supported in what's
called calendar is too much here too
our calendar team is working
alacrement  and to be able to release this
new version of the former and
interoperability that will allow
first of all to work with all
versions of the exchange but above all
also to go and see the information
in free and bisi then or from exchange
I will be able to see among invisi
on suite tolls on  internationa
therefore see the calendar and from the calendar I know
towards exchange and therefore this interregnum period will be much easier
because I will no longer have to foresee it however I
do not see the calendar I see it part but I
have to keep an outlook because otherwise it is not true
so the strong effort is in this
direction  it will be given at the end of the
slides and almost the end of time so
3k strong investment themes on which
we exist at the moment we have seen teams
then develop applications
so that they are easy to use to
work in a truly
collaborative way safety take
products more and more secure  but easy to
use that speaking in part in data
centers up to the end user
find features that simplify the
user's life the possibility of having
the platform that is integrated with
your environment that does not live in a
totally independent way but
the last one that I have already repeated the
usability therefore the possibility that you
product is really easy to
use to conclude one last
slide with which he basically wants to leave
is google is ready to
help accompany many faces in this passage
to the cloud advanced already do it
with sweets this slide what it
means meet you were you are dead
torpedoed therefore  the goal is to
support me to help you through
google directly through our
partners to be able to help you in this
step or for those who have done it in a
further and a further
qualitative leap
someone has started doing projects dg
suite because mail project
electronics then committee discover drivers
then started discovering
slides and so on started making a
change  cultural inside the
company
they kept me five minutes I have two
if there are any questions answered
otherwise so much I'm here and I wanted to
thank you there is a question please,
that is, the microphone arrives because if not up here it
will also be the age I do  it is hard to hear the
case of valerio milan in the event that there
are more people who manage an
e-mail account says for example
reservations at the domain sign points
more people using the same and
month it is before for example with exchange
they had both could respond in
this  case how does the person see
in the list is personal or
write for the municipal email
question to see if I heard correctly
then I a box that more people
access substantially both personal
and not
then if I have interpreted the
question correctly then possibly ne  we talk
offline and then there is a question of
share mailboxes as there is an exchange and
therefore the possibility of having a single
mailbox that is shared  visa by multiple users and
therefore I can access the same
box there is a discourse that
collaborative groups can be used which
therefore allow me to take care
of the help desk type request and
now but of this type and that allows me
to do these  two are the main methods
if instead we are talking about or to my
company mailbox and I also want to receive from
my personal mailbox or send with
my personal mailbox there is the possibility
within the gmail interface and to
go to mine the second
box so that a single
entry point to have my boxes done
then drag because from a little dull
but I try to interpret and are only
these three 15 m boxes with boxing labor day
then groups as with the
collaborative boxing box and possibly  the
possibility instead of loosening my
company mailbox to also receive my
personal mail
there was a question the 12 10 seconds to one
evening but it was a pleasure to p  iace I want to
ask the file stream will be a
feature is available only for
google drive for gi suite or even for
private google drive and then on which
operating systems it will be available
then first question is if it will be
available both for are satisfied or
only on users or even on the
personal part is only g suite is therefore where
there is drive
and will be available to date that I know
on windows and mac os that I knew in
reality it is based on closed so
basically it could
also work on linux
because the concept is the same on which
on the cloud platform you have certainly
seen windows and osx in the documentation
I'm not sure about linux even if
technically it should work because
or external at the end to unix and the
mechanism you use together with
closed is the same that is used
on the cloud pa forum to hook the
la  part related to cloud storage
so chances are I have
seen these two mentioned so far but it
could be them  re its launch there is a
question here we have to go ok
I greet you and who to this question
see you below
[Applause]